[Musique]
le piano comme source d'inspiration et
de création barbara rose et jouanny on a
fait sa passion et son métier un rapport
profond à la musique qu'il emmène plus
loin dans la composition
il lui fallait donner une couleur à ses
notes voir ce que ces mélodies lui
faisais tu entends je me définis comme
une peintre musicolor en fait qui
composent qui compose avec avec la
musique la musique et les couleurs des
couleurs inspirées par la musique il y a
une dizaine d'années ce professeur de
piano au conservatoire de franconville
découvre la peinture de l'art
contemplatif qui transporte le visiteur
dans son univers musical
toutes les toiles sont à écouter
pourquoi parce que je pars en musique et
chaque toile est inspiré par une musique
en particulier et toutes les toiles on
peut les on peut les écouter en tapant
sur son téléphone le titre est là le
nom du compositeur une expérience
multisensorielle que cet artiste
réunionnaise partage à la galerie de
l'antenne de paris des peintures que
l'on peut contempler et écouter
l'origine de leur création
c'est rendre l'art contemporain
accessible aussi au grand public et et
de vivre une expérience différente à
travers la musique
et voilà c'est faire partager aussi mon
univers la galerie in de la réunion est
aussi un lieu qui se veut être un lieu
des changes et de valorisation des
artistes réunionnais et dans ce cadre là
nous accueillons régulièrement des
artistes pour proposer au public de
découvrir les talents réunionnais à
travers des expositions peintures
parfois aussi de sculptures et nous
sommes là à leur écoute prêts à les
aider l aspect d accompagner une
peinture à écouter c'est le nom de son
exposition visible jusqu'au 6 janvier
prochain à l'antenne de paris
[Musique]